[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire
le revenu de base est de retour l'idée
défendue par benoît hamon lors de la
dernière campagne présidentielle
profitent de la crise sociale du haut
que 8,19 pour refaire surface
des personnalités de tous bords
socialistes écologistes communistes ou
néo libérale en font la promotion
que ce soit pour remplacer toutes les
aides qui existent déjà qui ce cumul qui
sont compliquées à obtenir et qui laisse
pas mal de demandes en chemin ou pour
parer au dénuement de ceux qui justement
sont restés au bord de la route et
notamment une partie de la jeunesse
après tout ceux qui sont favorables ne
sont pas forcément d'accord sur son
organisation doit-il être universel sans
condition de revenu est reversée à tous
les français aux plus pauvres quant aux
plus riches de la naissance jusqu'à la
mort
et de quel montant s'agirait-il pour en
débattre plus tôt pour débattre de
toutes ces questions nous avons quatre
invités qui sont pour ou contre le
revenu de base le premier c'est génial
zamora qui est sociologue professeur à
l'université libre de bruxelles post
doctorant à l'université de cambridge
vous êtes l'un des coauteurs de
contrôler location universel paru aux
éditions lux alors pourquoi êtes vous
contre alors je pense que la première
raison tout simplement qu'en focalisant
sur cette idée de blanche et de revenus
elle met un peu de côté une des
questions qui me semble la plus
importante aujourd'hui qu'est celle des
inégalités à savoir des écarts entre les
riches et les pauvres et la deuxième
aspect je pense aussi c'est peut-être
qu'en focalisant sur la question
soulevée sur moniteur toute la question
des services publics des services qu'on
pourrait avoir en dehors du marché et
mis un peu de côté dans ce débat li kath
& kim jee vous vous êtes référente
plaidoyer au mouvement français pour un
revenu de base un mouvement né en mars
2013 qui s'est donné pour mission de
promouvoir un revenu de base
inconditionnel universel cumulable avec
d'autres revenus de la naissance jusqu'à
la mort
alors pourquoi êtes vous favorable à un
tel revenu
ben personnellement déjà un infirmier je
suis venu au revenu de base
par son caractère émancipatoire je me
posais pas mal de questions sur la place
du travail dans la société sur les choix
que je voulais faire les choix de vie
que je voulais faire donc c'est comme ça
que je suis suis venu mais de manière
plus générale pour nous c'est un moyen
c'est une c'est un droit et non une aide
et ça c'est très important notamment
pour la lutte contre la pauvreté mais
aussi contre les inégalités et ça j'y
reviendrai en répondant à daniel zamora
il ne s'agit pas contrairement aux aides
que l'on connaît habituellement de
stigmatiser de vérifier si quelqu un à
un et sous un seuil de revenus ou tout
ça on le distribue à tout le monde mais
ce sera peut-être la différence que je
veux je ferai avec la définition que
vous donniez où vous disiez que certains
pour un revenu de base en dessous d'un
certain seuil non pour nous le revenu de
base
il doit être universel inconditionnel et
individuelles pascal salin vous vous
êtes économiste professeur rené
honoraire à l'université paris dauphine
ex président de la société du mont
pèlerin fondée par friedrich hayek par
karl popper et milton friedman vous êtes
toujours opposé vous revenu universel
pourquoi pour plusieurs raisons la
première est une raison de principes à
savoir que c'est supposé que les
bénéficiaires de ce revenu universel
sans ont des droits jeu gîte de
respecter ses droits au prix y est
éthique des autres en deuxième lieu
transférer des ressources sans savoir
pour quelles raisons certains ont des
ressources faibles à un moment donné ça
me paraît contestable
et puis il ya des conséquences pratiques
importantes à savoir que le revenu
universel un site un certain nombre de
gens à ne pas travailler ou à travailler
moins et veut par contre comme il faut
les financer
ça implique nécessairement une
augmentation des impôts
et pour ceux qui ont certains revenus et
donc que ça l'est ça détruit leurs
incitations à travailler par exemple à
entreprendre et tout le monde subit
conséquent alors barque de basquiat vous
êtes ingénieur et économiste vous êtes
membre de génération libre un think tank
d'inspiration libérale qui promeut les
libertés toutes les libertés et vous
présidez l'association pour
l'instauration d'un revenu d'existence
vous avez d'ailleurs publié avec gaspard
koenig libère un revenu de liberté pour
tous aux éditions de l'ondh
le tome ii une proposition réaliste est
paru trois ans après c'est l'explication
technique du projet je précise que
nathalie kosciusko morizet candidate à
la primaire de la droite en 2016 s'était
inspiré de vos idées pour son programme
pourquoi vous êtes favorable à un revenu
de base moi le premier critère c'est
l'ingrédient de liberté effectivement
elle me paraît évident que dans une
société quelles que soient les personnes
qui vivent en communautés qui vivent
collectivement doit pouvoir exprimer
leur liberté en faisant des choix
rationnels de vie en prenant à un
travail en prenant une activité
reprenant des études et donc quelque
part la société doit favoriser le fait
que les personnes puissent avoir une vie
une réelle liberté s'être libéré liberté
on la voit par le fait que les personnes
peuvent aller à l'école
une ouverture d'école qui est universel
les personnes qu'elles sont malades
peuvent aller à l'hôpital donc là il ya
la santé est universel et donc on
logement il ya les arguments qui sont
ouvertes pour le logement et le fait
d'assurer sa subsistance est également
un besoin universel et pour moi je
voudrais qu'une raison de dire qu'il
faudrait que les gens fassent des choses
extrêmes sont extrêmement particulière
pour obtenir ce droit de vivre grâce à
ce revenu universel
alors on voit bien que c'est un problème
d'abord philosophique un le
le revenu de base universel ou pas
d'ailleurs on en parlera après mais
l'idée que la collectivité doit verser
un revenu à chacun de ses membres sans
rien lui demander en contrepartie on
voit bien que ça pose une question
philosophique et au fond on se demande
est ce que c'est juste
est ce que c'est juste que on donne à
chacun un revenu sans contrepartie et
pour ça il faut qu'il y en ait qui
travaille pour que d'autres à un moment
puisse ne pas travailler
est ce que c'est juste parce qu'elle
cela vous avez l'air de dire non ça
n'est pas juste a et a l'air d'avoir un
bug avec pascal ça n'a pas l'air de
m'entendre alors je pose la même année
sur ses saillies et rim entend non eelv
entend pas daniel zamora
oui c'est une bonne question moi j'aurai
je suis évidemment plus moins critique
sur ce plan-là je pense qu'il n'ya pas
c'est pas la raison pour laquelle je m'y
opposerai c'est à dire que les sociétés
trouvent différentes manières de
redistribuer de garantir un certain
niveau d'existence garantir la santé
l'éducation les différentes méthodes
peuvent être prises pour garantir cela
la question qui conquit moi petit bras
se posent avec leur omniscience
effectivement la modalité qu'on va faire
et une exemple qui vient tout de suite à
l'esprit c'est l'exemple de hong kong
donc comme pour une série d'années avait
surplus budgétaires importants et en
2011 ils ont décidé de diviser la somme
de ce surplus budgétaire par le nombre
d'habitants et d'envoyer à chacun un
chèque pour qu'ils puissent faire ce
qu'il entend avec et on pourrait
évidemment tout à fait imaginer c'est là
la question et c'est pour moi le coeur
du débat
quand l'heure et il était si on avait
réuni l'ensemble des citoyens de hong
kong pour discuter de ce que je pouvais
faire de cet argent
ensemble il aura peut-être décidé de
créer des crèches gratuites d'investir
dans l'éducation de augmenter les
ressources de la santé et donc celle de
la modalité de la décision est ce que
c'est une décision qui est collective
qui est démocratique
ou est ce qu'elle va être simplement
souvenir des choix de consommation
individus
l'ue et chacun décide de faire ce qu'il
entend et croise à décines deux visions
de la redistribution qui sont
radicalement différent évidemment
l'iccat et quand jimmy alors oui sur le
caractère juste ou non alors qu'ils ne
travaillent pas en fait j'ai envie de
dire et qu'est ce qu'est le travail on
est bénévole on travaille actuellement
je suis bénévole
enfin j'ai aussi un travail rémunéré
d'autre part le travail domestique c'est
du travail aussi le fait d'élever ses
enfants c'est du travail le fait
d'assister à un parent âgé
c'est du travail le fait d'aider tout
simplement donc en fait c'est aussi se
poser la question de caisse qu'elle
travaille on a trop tendance à faire
dans notre tête l'équivalence entre le
travail et l'emploi où le travail est
quelque chose de rémunérer n'ont pas
forcément il y à pas mal de choses qui
sont faites on peut le voir en ce moment
quand dans la critique au vide il ya pas
mal d'associations qui ont vraiment
permis
nos deux je pense aux jeunes notamment
des associations comme link qui comme
copains qui se met en mouvement et qui
permettent vraiment de dd là où
peut-être que les pouvoirs publics
même s'il essaye de faire des choses
n'ont pour l'instant pas réussi vraiment
à prendre leur place donc encore une
fois qu'ils ne travaillent pas et je
peins j'aimerais dire les quelqu'un qui
est au chômage
demander enfin vous avez sûrement des
chômeurs ou des chômeurs autour de vous
il ne demande qu'à travailler
c'est à dire qu'à travailler avec un
travail rémunéré mais aussi plus
largement 4 contribuer à la société est
quelque part on y contribuent tous un
petit peu à notre manière oui mais il
faut bien préciser que dans le cas d'un
revenu universel sans condition on ne
demande rien en contrepartie aux gens
leur demande pas de faire ni ni d'être
membre d'une association ni de faire du
baby-sitting rien s'ils ont envie de
rester chez eux ils restent chez eux ils
font ce qu'ils veulent c'est la liberté
dont par les marques debesque
vous pascal salin oui oui oui oui pardon
annoncé les trois mêmes questions
pourquoi ça dépasse juste à votre avis
mais parce que parmi les parmi les les
raisons que j'ai déjà exprimées ya par
exemple le fait que l'on ne sait pas
quelles sont les raisons pour lesquelles
certains on est revenu nous le nul ou
faible que le revenu ils essaient ans et
est attribué à tout le monde mais il
faut bien qu'ils soient payés alors ceux
qui payent pas d'impôt sur le revenu par
exemple ils reçoivent le revenu
universel mais ils ont rien à payer en
contrepartie
alors que d'autres au contraire doivent
payer beaucoup plus qu'ils ne reçoivent
comme revenu universel
ce qui veut bien dire exemple parce
qu'en france qui a à peu près 50% des
gens qui payent pas d'impôt sur le
revenu
ça veut dire que ceux qui payent le
moins d'impôts sont ceux qui bénéficient
du revenu universel et il faut se
demander
je crois que il faut se demander
pourquoi je prends juste un exemple
imaginons deux individus qui se sont les
mêmes capacités et qui sont capables de
recevoir sur la totalité de leur vie
exactement le même revenu mais il y en a
un qui a des revenus très variable avec
des périodes où il reçoit rien du tout
comme revenu et l'autre au contraire
reçoit tout le temps donc celui qui a
des revenus variables il va bénéficier
lorsqu'il n'a pas de salaire à certaines
périodes
il va bénéficier du revenu universel qui
sera en fait payés par l'autre terrain
comme une injustice
puisqu'ils ont les mêmes capacités elle
est même revenu dans leur vie mais là
qui sont obligés par la contrainte
publics de financer indirectement un
autre c'est un exemple parmi beaucoup
d'exemples que l'on pourrait prendre
bien entendu les jeunes la question
qu'il faut se poser
c'est précisément de ceux demandés sont
les activités vie du et pourquoi de
financer certains alors je suis bien
d'accord sur une idée à savoir que la
générosité c'est quelque chose qui est
louable et les êtres humains ont
toujours éprouvé de la solidarité
vis-à-vis des gens qui étaient démunis
mais considèrent comme justifiée du
point de vue éthique c'est précisément
les décisions prises par des individus
ou des associations de financer certains
pères certaines personnes qui ont des
besoins particuliers et qui ont des
raisons de ne pas pouvoir avoir des
raisons justifiées de pas pouvoir avoir
plus élevé mais en faire quelque chose
de systématique qui revient à faire des
transferts de deux parcs forcément bien
connu entre un certain nombre de
citoyens d'autres ça ça me paraît tout à
fait contestable
nate de bastia c'est un peu étrange
c'est cette logique qui consiste à dire
qu'il faudrait que les que les riches ne
payent pas c'est que c'est curieux
sachant que quand une personne se
retrouve son travail nous allons en vue
quand même des millions même des
dizaines de millions pendant l'année
2020 avec les crésus qu'ovide n'en veut
une situation où de nombreuses personnes
de très nombreuses personnes se sont
retrouvées privées de leurs activités
normales et s'il fallait bien que s'ils
sont que ce serait à eux de payer leurs
revenus alors qu'ils n'ont plus
d'activité est quelque chose qui est un
peu étonnant donc qu'on y mettre une
logique du revenu vers celle qui veut
dire dans une collectivité nationale
parmi tous les habitants de ce pays il y
à un principe de solidarité qu'ils très
clair déjà aujourd'hui avec la santé qui
est très claire aujourd'hui avec une
éducation qui est très claire sur un
certain nombre de prestations et ses
mécanismes là on sait sur qui sont
vraiment général plutôt que de faire ce
qu'on fait actuellement du bricolage où
il y tient vous voulez dans telle
situation vous avez droit ceci nous a
présenté notre situation et droit à cela
et ainsi de suite
et voici les règles
si et voici pourquoi ils vont vous
l'enlever et ainsi de suite non l'idée
c'est de dire voilà chaque être humain a
besoin d'un socle de revenus pour se
nourrir tous les jours tous les matins
l'être humain a besoin de savoir ce qui
mettra dans son assiette pour se nourrir
ceci est une règle absolue et donc il
n'y a aucune explication sur le fait
qu'on peut dire ab vous n'aurez pas le
droit non c'est juste pas possible
d'entendre chaque être humain la
nécessité de se nourrir chaque jour et
donc il faut une solution systématique
sans aucune condition à ce niveau daniel
zamora
j'aimerais avoir votre sentiment
là-dessus baisse qu'a priori vous êtes
sensible à cet argument
on a un système de protection sociale on
s'en est aperçu avec le co vide où sont
généralement les plus prisées qui traque
qui passent à travers les mailles du
filet là tout le monde s'en est aperçu
on a un système de protection sociale
qui est basé sur l'exclusion plus que
sur l'inclusion
on est très méfiant on a toujours peur
de verser quelque chose à des mauvais
pauvres qui au fond profiterait du
système et c'est cette peur qui fait
qu'on demande en permanence des preuves
avant de verser des aides qu'ils ont
souvent petit et qu'on cumule pourquoi
ne pas remplacer sa part une aide
systématique à tout le monde
inclusive qui ne laisserait personne au
bord de la route c'est une bonne
question serait qu' une des raisons qui
ont cédé très attractif je pense que
c'est précisément son universalité et la
simplicité
on sait tout le monde la reçoit
automatiquement à partir de certains
critères peut-être à la majorité alpes
avant mais cette automaticité rend
évidemment le modèle particulièrement
attractif dans le système dans lequel on
sait que beaucoup de personnes ne sont
pas beaucoup à leurs droits parfois ils
ont droit à des aides minable il ne
demande pas qu'on ne la reçoivent pas et
puis c'est un système qui est très pâle
parfois compliqué et c'est donc ça c'est
vrai que il ya une critique qui est tout
à fait légitime et que le et des
systèmes aujourd'hui protection sociale
devrait être simplifiée devrait
certainement être automatisés après ce
cette simplicité
je pense au ch'ti
constitue le point faible de
l'allocation universelle c'est-à-dire
que les la société dans laquelle on vit
une vie est très inégale dans lesquelles
il ya des besoins qui sont très
différents et dans des modèles
j'avais dit réaliste c'est à dire qu'on
peut financer qui ne demandent pas de
deux engagés 20% du pib donc en mettons
une allocation universelle à 300-400 pas
les 2 500 euros
cette somme qui est envoyé à tout le
monde pour certains qui en ont vraiment
besoin elle n'est pas suffisante et pour
d'autres qui ne l'ont pas besoin comme
moi par exemple il est absolument pas
nécessaire et donc très rapidement ce
qui fait l'attractivité du système se
transforme en une gigantesque machine
qui vise à déplacer des sommes d'argent
mais pas nécessairement dans les bonnes
poches pour donner juste un peu et
exemple pour abolir la pauvreté donc si
on voulait aligner les prestations
minimales au seuil de pauvreté
on pourrait également les automatiser
aujourd'hui s'il ya une volonté
politique de les automatiser on pourrait
les faire et ouvriers val accès à toute
une série de prestations à tous ceux qui
en ont besoin
ça pourrait coûter entre un peu moins de
2% du pib ce n'est pas gigantesque c'est
quand même une réforme importante
n'était pas gigantesque une allocation
universelle de 500 euros et un coup très
rapidement 16% du pib si on ne la
substitut par d'autres choses sur la
joute aux prestations existantes et donc
pourquoi dépenser plus alors qu'on peut
faire la même chose avec beaucoup moins
et que avec le reste on peut peut-être
investir dans l'éducation à investir
dans la santé a besoin important dans
les maisons de retraite
donc tout ça ici il ya vraiment une
question sur l'attractivité du modèle
est aussi au fond son point faible
parce que les besoins sont différents
ils ne sont pas les mêmes c'est
universalité pose question
les catégories effectivement si c'est ce
que vous proposez un c'est que ce soit
un revenu universel sans conditions de
revenus
donc ça veut dire que je le touche vous
le touchez tous les quatre tout le monde
ne touche même ceux et surtout seul qui
donne n'ont pas besoin donc quel dommage
on aurait pu si on avait tout mis tout
ça en commun s'offrir un bel hôpital
tout neuf il ya plein de gens qui vont
vous dire ça qu'est-ce que vous avez
leur répondre non mais c'est déjà ce
qu'on fait aujourd'hui enfin c'est ce
qu'on fait depuis depuis quarante voire
voir que le voir 50 ans d essayer de
cibler et de donner à ceux qui en ont
besoin et de donner aux pauvres du coup
on voit qu'on a plein de problèmes pour
ça notamment déjà européen repérer les
personnes qui en ont vraiment besoin
il ya aussi plein de deux remparts tels
que tel que les remparts administratif
il ya des gens qui ne demandent pas les
aides donc je suis d'accord une première
étape ce serait une automatisation des
aides actuelles mais sur l'argument de
dire il n'y en a qui en ont pas besoin
mais en plaques de revenu universel il
faut pas oublier qu'il doit être financé
ça c'est sûr et il est financé par la
contribution nationale
voilà on va chercher l'argent là où il y
en a donc de toutes façons si vous en
est si vous gagnez assez pour pour
subvenir à vos besoins et enfin plus
vous allez de toute façon rembourser
leurs billets de base quoi qu'il arrive
donc un monsieur françois pinault va
payer plusieurs fois ce qui va recevoir
un revenu de base le système il est
simple est-ce que c'est ce qui a été
rappelé par daniels moi et c'est ça qui
fait qu' il est efficace il donne sans
contreparties sont demandés de dossiers
sont demandés de vérification dans en
termes de revenus cela ce sera après
coup fait par l'imposition par le
système fiscal
pascal sala oui je voudrais revenir à à
cette question sur laquelle il est
important de savoir pour connu nulle ou
faible
je vais faire une comparaison entre deux
deux cas différents le premier que j'ai
d'ailleurs déjà souligné c'est le fait
qu'il y à une variabilité considérable
dans certains certains revenus mais il
me semble que de ce point de vue là ce
qui est important pour financer et les
gens dans les périodes où ils ont des
revenus faibles ou nulles
ce qui serait important ce serait un
système tu as super acteur mais on
pourrait imaginer des systèmes
d'assurance ratant très mal pascal salin
il ya un problème
ça va être la pause dans trois minutes
on va on va tâcher de vérifier que le
système je donne la parole à la marque
de baskets je vous donnerai la parole au
retour après la pause marque de bastia
il nous reste trois minutes là on va
rentrer e minute effectivement j'ai
entendu daniel zamora qui expliquait
quelques chiffres 1 point sociologue
chose de bien j'aime bien quand même ce
surcoût sur des chiffres voilà pour les
travailler en tant qu'économiste et sur
la sélection française et l'association
que je préside et travaille dur et tous
les jours il vient tous les jours sans
celui là depuis 31 ans
donc nous avons des chiffres assez
précis sur le cas français en
particulier sur le cas français
ce que je peux vous dire déjà c'est que
les personnes qui ont des revenus
relativement aisé au dessus il 25000
euros par part fiscale
aujourd'hui leurs impôts se calcule à 30
% de leur revenu imposable moins 500
euros par mois
ces calculs actuels de l'impôt je re
nomme ses 500 euros revenu universel et
déjà ceux qui sont dans ces tranches de
revenus ont déjà 500 euros par mois sans
s'en rendre compte
parce que c'est déjà inclus dans le
calcul de l'impôt et personnes qui sont
en rsa qui sont en bas de la
distribution des revenus
quant à koné seules célibataires au rsa
on est aujourd'hui 80 euros c'est-à-dire
500 euros par mois
et c'est déjà la norme et on est prélevé
à hauteur d'environ 30% des revenus donc
cette règle 500 euros moins 30 % c'est
vrai qu'il existe déjà pour les revenus
élevés comme pour les revenus faibles et
donc il est assez facile d'un point de
vue économique et napoli fiscal ne
mettront pas une solution
qui fait la liaison entre la situation
sociale des pauvres citons fiscales des
riches techniquement c'est extrêmement
simple et ça ne coûte pas très cher
vous avez fait même moins de trois
minutes qui nous en reste un peu
daniel zamora oui bah écoutez va pas
faire un débat sur les chiffres parce
qu'évidemment c'est un peu c'est un peu
technique est compliqué mais je pense
que marc de basquiat sera d'accord pour
dire que et ça c'est peut-être la
question que j'avais apportées au début
c'est que ce n'est pas un système qui
vise à réduire les inégalités sur modèle
lui même dans son propre livre à des
effets redistributifs assez faible et ça
me semble qu'un est une négation
centrale aujourd'hui c'est pas
simplement le plancher en dessous duquel
on ne devrait pas sombrer c'est aussi
les écarts de revenus entre les riches
et les pauvres et le fait qu'aujourd'hui
il ya des gens qui amassent des fortunes
obscène est une question soit c'est pas
simplement celle du plancher minimum au
dessus duquel les gens de ne devrait pas
cependant d'interrompre daniel zamora
mais est-ce que ça n'est pas un autre
sujet à vrai dire là on parle d'un de la
revenu vital d'un revenu d'existence peu
importe le nom qu'on lui donne à savoir
que je suis tout un chacun qu'il
travaille ou qu'ils ne travaillent pas
puissent venir à ses besoins on s'en
fout on j'allais dire c'est pas le même
sujet que de savoir qu'il ya quelqu'un
il ya dix personnes dans le monde qui
gagne 1 milliard e
c'est pas le jeu c'est pas le même sujet
si forcément cette même changé ce n'est
pas le même sujet c'est vrai mais la
séparation de ces deux questions me
semble en soi problématique c'est une
séparation qui a vraiment eu lieu à
marquer des années 70 on a commencé à
vivre au fond si les riches devenez plus
riches c'est pas grave tong époque sur
moins de pauvres aurait au final ce qui
s'est passé c'est que les riches sont
devenus plus riches et le nombre de
bovins n'a pas baissé de manière
substantielle
donc ça je pense que c'est quand même
une question importante et deuxièmement
il reste qu'il n'en reste pas moins que
le revenu que propose ma de basket à
1500 euros qui ne sont pas non plus
surestimer les effets sur la pauvreté de
500 euros c'est quand même pas quelque
chose qui va vous permettre de choisir
de ne pas travailler de subvenir
totalement vos besoins non vous allez
devoir aller sur le marché de l'emploi
vous allez devoir trouver un travail et
payer votre loyer et vous pouvez
demander à la plupart des gens
est-ce que 500 euros permettent de
subvenir correctement ses besoins oui
alors après la question du montant de ce
revenu de base c'est un autre sujet mais
je propose de faire une pause on se
retrouve juste après fin janvier des
petits investisseurs sont parvenus à se
coordonner sur internet pour faire plier
de grands fonds d'investissement
rassurez-vous vous avez quelqu'un qui en
ont bien profité qui ont mis à genoux un
iphone mais comme comme on faisait déjà
depuis je vous dis 30 ans de la seule
différence est l'effet de foule s'est
organisée sur des réseaux sociaux donc
c'est un peu la version 3.0 des
opérations organisées entre
investisseurs ne faut pas considérer ça
comme la révolution des petits contre
les gros et c'est non cdti beaucoup plus
malins qui sont des grosses mains et qui
ont organisé leur coup on nous vend un
peu le conte de fées que c'est que des
sardines qui ont attaqué le requin est
en fait je pense que parmi les sardines
y avait aussi des ruptures
[Musique]
des accords d'abraham change les
équilibres stratégiques pour le
moyen-orient après 50 ans d'immobilisme
dans cette région complète tron était le
seul à pouvoir créer les conditions
d'une paix durable grâce à ses relations
différentes avec tous les acteurs
le problème est maintenant de voir
comment joe biden va traiter un sujet
s'il relance l'accord actuel des accords
d'abraham resteront une alliance
stratégique contre l'iran qui unira les
pays de la région et réglera les
relations avec israël
l'europe se cantonne dans le rôle de
spectateur sceptiques en ayant
totalement minimiser la dynamique créée
par les accords de bras si tout se
déroule comme l'envisageait donald trump
et ses négociateurs 2020 n'aura pas été
seulement l'année de lakovic 19
elle sera aussi celle des accords de
branche
[Musique]
repro ce débat sur le revenu de base
avec daniel zamora qu'est sociologue
c'est l'un des coauteurs de contrôle
allocation universelle avec l'iccat est
conduit du mouvement français pour un
revenu de base
pascal salin lui et économistes mais
pour l'instant on a une mauvaise liaison
donc qu'on est en train d'essayer de le
récupérer et enfin marc de bastia qui
est le président de l'association pour
l'instauration d'un revenu d'existence
c'est lui qui a publié avec gaspard
koenig libère un revenu de liberté pour
tous
daniel zamora la de l'air de dire que le
revenu de base universel
ça coûte très cher donc c'est
nécessairement très faible celui que
vous proposez marque
c'est ce serait environ 2 500 euros on
peut difficilement vivre avec 500 euros
donc on n'a pas fait un progrès
considérable que vous en pensez licques
et écologie vous aussi vous êtes pour un
revenu universel donc tout le monde ne
toucherai si tout le monde le touche
c'est forcément à revenus faibles n'ont
pas forcé non alors le jeu connaît bien
le le revenu universel que propose marc
de bastien donc effectivement à 500
euros donc le niveau d'un rsa sans
forfait logement alors ce modèle il a le
mérite de montrer la différence entre le
coût brut on attribue souvent un revenu
universel et le coût net en fait c'est à
dire qui va au final le recevoir c'est à
dire faire la différence entre la
réception du revenu universel
est ce qu'on va ce qu'on va le donner
fiscalement à l'état enfin des impôts à
la solidarité nationale et donc enfin
marc l'expliquera mieux que moi mais
finalement ce modèle il est il est pas
si il ne coûte pas si cher que ça en est
maintenant c'est vrai que si on veut
aller plus loin que 500 euros
nous on envisage on a pas de montant
fixe à l'association pour remplacer le
rsa certes il faut qu'il soit au niveau
du rsa au minimum pour remplacer les
ailes il faut qu'il soit à la hauteur de
ses oeuvres
mais on peut penser à des niveaux de
benoît hamon annoncé 600 600 750 euros
en 2017 on peut aller on peut imaginer
800 certains parlent même d'atteindre le
seuil de pauvreté à 60 % c'est-à-dire
1000 euros alors effectivement ça coûte
beaucoup plus cher mais du coup c'est
une aubaine si on se dit vraiment qu'on
veut donner un minimum pour une vie
digne à chacun si on décide de sa enfin
tant que société du coup ça veut dire
faire une grande réforme fiscale au voir
une révolution fiscale et pour cela
alors certes il y à l'impôt sur le
revenu mais ce sera pas suffisant et il
faudra aller chercher du côté de delà du
patrimoine voir vraiment comment on peut
taxer le patrimoine
sachant que les inégalités de patrimoine
sont beaucoup plus fortes et ont
augmenté ces dernières années par
rapport aux inégalités de revenus qui
sont déjà conséquente
il ya d'autres desseins par exemple la
taxe sur les transactions financières
transactions financières aujourd'hui un
génère des sommes immenses
il suffit d'une d'une micro taxe il ya
des liens et je sais pas si les
économistes chercheurs mais qui est
qu'il est franco suisse qui s'appelle
marché n'est qu'ils travaillent sur ce
thème est d'ailleurs ce sujet va être
soumis à un référendum suisse donc le
sujet de la micro taxe c'est à dire
faire des micro taxe sur les
transactions financières ce qui aurait
en plus pour effets bénéfiques de
ralentir un peu la machine au système
financier
enfin tout ce qui est spéculation tout
ça donc il y a pas mal d'autres pistes
explorées
bon on voit par exemple avec open nul
surtout ça allait la faire sur tout ce
qui est luxembourg qui a aussi des
pistes côte évasion fiscale est ce que
si on décide ensemble de donner un
minimum vital à chacun qui soit assez
conséquent est ce que ce n'est pas
l'occasion de mettre ça sur la table et
de faire une vraie révolution fiscale
marque
heureusement pascal salin est revenu je
suis sûr qu'il a beaucoup de choses à
dire
sur le sujet l'iccat est conduit
n'hésite pas à dire qu'il faut taxer le
patrimoine taxer la finance
taxer les paradis fiscaux faire une
révolution fiscale tout ça pour
instaurer un revenu universel qui soit
plus de 500 euros j'imagine que vous
avez beaucoup d'arguments contre
maintenant vous après cette petite voix
[Musique]
non dès lors vous a fait une voix de
mickey pascal salin c'est du sabotage
attendez attendez ajouté je vous entend
plus on va encore faire quelques
réparations et je donne la parole à marc
de bastia je suis navré il faut qu'ils
iraient qui résolvent ce problème marque
alors sur ce sujet-là du montant je
pense qu'il faut être extrêmement clair
quand j'évoque 500 euros je ne dis pas
que je veux que ce soit 500 euros
mon avis n'a aucune importance moi je
suis plus président d'une association
qui travaille sur le sujet je ne sommes
pas en train de décider quoi que ce soit
ce que nous disons c'est que instaurer
un revenu universel de 500 euros par
personne individuelle qui soit
systématique ça se financent très
simplement par une femme de l'impôt sur
le revenu aujourd'hui il ya une tranche
à 30% ont conscience et tranche là et on
peut tout à fait mettre en place un
revenu universel de 500 euros avec un
prélèvement de 30% et ça coûte quasiment
rien sur les coûts et 2 % + 7 %
c'est tout ça interrompt parce que vous
ne me fixe pas grave nous l'avait
expliqué ça mais pour qu'il soit plus
consistants dans ce conflit ce vraiment
vivre pour qu'on puisse vraiment être
libre puisque vous le dites vous même
c'est pour ça que vous voulez la
stresser pour qu'on soit libre et vous
savez bien qu'il faudra plus donc est ce
que vous êtes d'accord vous qui êtes
plutôt libérale pour qu'on taxe qu'on
taxe tout le monde qu'on taxe le
patrimoine qu'on taxe les transactions
financières contexte le capital contexte
où pour instaurer un revenu
universelle qui soit conséquent je vous
reconnais là le revenu universel
c'est un soc il ya deuxième sac c'est
l'aide au logement
une personne seule aujourd'hui alain rsa
dans le 500 euros plus une aide au
logement de l'ordre de 300 euros
c'est l'effet 800 euros non ce que nous
proposons c'est 500 euros l'hl universel
sans aucune démarche systématique sans
rien demander à personne et connaît en
couple ça fait x 2 c'est à dire mille
euros aujourd'hui c'est 700 euros qu'on
est con et 2 est déjà un complément
quand les deux et ensuite les aides au
logement c'est un plus ensuite cogné
avec handicap et du plus quand il des
problèmes divers et variés du plus mais
pas les objectifs
si on dit que 500 ça va pas c'est pas
moi qui vais le dire ce sont les
représentants de la nation
les députés les politiques qui vont en
discuter qui vont dire que c'est pas 500
ses 550 600 je n'ai aucun avis sur la
question
s'il faut monter l'impôt pour monter le
niveau je n'ai aucun avis c'est une
décision purement politique qui
regardent la représentation nationale
ce n'est pas une question à poser un
expert
si un expert répondre à cette question
ce n'est pas un expert c'est un
idéologue
j'ai fait une grande différence alors d
amora qui ne veut pas non plus être un
idéologue mais qui n'est pas contre le
fait d'un peu de d'augmenter les impôts
surtout les impôts des riches mais pas
pour restaurer le revenu universel c'est
à dire que voilà est-ce que l' usage le
plus efficient que l'on peut faire de
admettons si on lâche 3 la fondation
jean jaurès à faire une simulation pour
une allocation universelle à 1000 euros
et le montant représentait 2 31 % du pib
ça vire le budget de la santé de
l'éducation nationale et de toutes les
prestations sociales réunis alors que
trop est une série de mécanismes pour
réduire of ce montant mais est ce que
vraiment
la manière la plus utile de dépenser cet
argent à d'envoyer un chèque à tout le
monde
voilà ça je n'en suis pas convaincu et
je pense que la deuxième le deuxième
aspect c'est celui sur lesquels on était
revenu un petit peu tout à l'heure c'est
aussi cette focalisation sur l'aspect
monétaire ce que j'appuie ce que
j'appelle la monétisation de la pauvreté
est pauvre c'est manquer d'argent alors
c'est vrai mais être pauvre c'est aussi
manqué de logements manqué d'éducation
manqué de santé manqué peut-être de
crèches publiques
si demain on investit dans la petite
enfance
et si on garantit par exemple que ce
secteur soit accessible à tous sera
également un impact sur la pauvreté
parce que beaucoup de familles
monoparentales sont pauvres et donc on
peut aussi réduire d'une certaine façon
la dépendance à l'argent en offrant plus
de services et donc il ya deux bouts par
lequel on peut voir la pauvreté et se
focaliser uniquement sur l'aspect
monétaire
c'est aussi peut-être oublié ce qui a
façonné l'esprit d'état social tel qu'il
a été conçu après guerre qui visait
précisément à soustraire les individus
de l'emprise du marché et ça je pense
que voilà il ya peut-être quelque chose
mais daniel zamora on voit aussi bien on
l'a vu avec la crise du coc vide que
sont toujours les mêmes je le disais
tout à l'heure qui passent à travers les
mailles du filet c'est ce qu'ils ont pas
assez travaillé c'est ceux qui n'ont pas
d'enfant c'est ce qu'ils sont pas
inscrits au rsa c'est ce qu'ils savent
pas quoi ils ont droit
et puis c'est les jeunes les jeunes
aujourd'hui on voit bien c'est les
premières victimes de la de la griffe du
coc vides et alors on aura beau
ouvrir des crèches on résoudra pas le
problème de tous ces gens là bien sûr la
question ici n'est pas de dire qu'on est
fondamentalement contre que je serais
content de rencontrer les transferts il
faut des transferts ya toute une série
de dispositifs qui vont garantir un
revenu à chacun encore une fois la
question c'est est ce qu'il faut le
donner à tout le monde ça ça me semble
compliqué pas philosophiquement je ne
serai pas opposé par principe mais parce
que à vouloir le donner à tout le monde
et bien on donne pas assez à ceux qui en
ont vraiment besoin est trop à ceux qui
ne l'ont pas besoin je pense qu'il ya
quand même voilà ici un arbitrage à
faire on ne peut pas simplement sortir
de son chapeau des millions pour donner
à tout le monde
et deuxièmement je pense aussi qu'on
peut réduire cette dépendance est que
les étudiants c'est aussi la question le
coût de l'éducation le goût des
transports si demain les transports sont
gratuits c'est quand même quelque chose
qui va changer leur quotidien et qu'on
doit penser ces questions sur ces deux
aspects on doit tenir c'est debout
ensemble pour pouvoir avancer
pascal salin est de retour j'espère avec
sa voix oui je crois qu'il est important
de continuer ce qu'on sait les
ressources que des individus obtenir ce
constant leurs groupies et il est
possible de réaliser un peu en par
différents systèmes les assurances gens
peu aux états unis les les étudiants ils
payent leurs études mais ils empruntent
pour cela et remboursent ultérieurement
c'est à dire que l'heureux leurs revenus
futurs sont un petit peu diminué ce qui
compte essentiellement c'est de savoir
si la nécessité d'avoir des transferts
de certains individus à d'autres
individus des transferts de ressources
elle dépend de la variabilité des
ressources au cours de la vie et dans ce
cas là il veut je crois que là mais plus
encore
perdu pascal salin c'est vraiment une
malédiction marque de basquiat non lic à
thé conduit voulez vous l'êtes
intervenir en fait sur ce que disait
daniel zamora et sur ce qui est des
services publics nouveaux mouvements on
a une discussion en cours sur la
suffisance
c'est vrai que le thème de la suffisance
c'est à dire à partir de quel montant
on estime qu' on a une vie digne
effectivement on voit très bien que
qu'il est difficile d'attribuer un
montant sans penser à tout ce qu'il ya
autour c'est à dire là où système de
protection sociale dont la sécurité
sociale où tous les systèmes
assurantiels mais aussi les tout ce qui
est gratuite et et services publics qui
peuvent varier en plus d'une ville à une
autre
et alors on n'a pas encore statué mais
on est en train de réfléchir à la
suffisance
c'est à dire au seuil en terme de sorte
de package quoi c'est à dire pas juste
en termes monétaires c'est-à-dire le
revenu universel qu'on estime être
suffisant mais ce revenu universel
intégré dans un environnement de de
protection sociale et de services
publics
alors est-ce qu'on peut pas se poser la
question autrement c'est-à-dire qu'au
lieu de faire de ce revenu de base à
revenu universel
est-ce qu'on peut pas imaginer certains
le font un revenu de base qui
remplacerait et qui élargirait le rsa
par exemple ou d'autres aides qui
viennent s'ajouter l'aide au logement
vous en parliez tout à l'heure
voilà de remplacer toutes ces aides là
qui sont ciblés qui sont des des petites
aides qui se cumulent les unes sur les
autres de les remplacer par un revenu de
base alors qu'il ne serait plus
universel ce qu'ils ont à partir d'un
certain revenu on ne les toucheraient
plus
donc ce serait ciblé là aussi mais ça
aurait le mérite de coûter beaucoup
moins cher à la collectivité
est ce que vous y avez pensé matt de
basquiat et
quand quelqu'un quelle conclusion en
avez-vous tiré ce que vous venez de
décrire en quelques mots cela correspond
à peu près à au projet du revenu
universel à des activités qui a été
lancé par le président par le président
macron en septembre 2018
nous sommes aujourd'hui en 2021 et
rennes est sorti pourtant les
administrations concernées et compte
travailler sur la question et il ya eu
trente institutions publiques comme
travis sujet du revenu sur ses activités
sous la direction te fait pertinente de
fabrice lenglart enfin travailler
absolument colossal je vous le dis ce
que je fais partie j'ai participé au
groupe d'experts d'urville à cette
activité est la conclusion que j'en tire
personnellement c'est qu'il est
extrêmement compliqué de simplifier
quelque chose qui est déjà une
complexité énorme et donc il ya un
moment il faut poser un schéma nouveau
qu' un schéma qui fait le lien entre le
social et le fiscal et là on peut faire
quelque chose beaucoup plus efficace et
qui fonctionne tant qu'on reste dans
l'idée de bricoler entre les différentes
mécaniques église c'est déjà pour les
ajuster les uns les autres
sachant qu'ils ont tous des règles très
différentes les uns par rapport aux
autres
il est extrêmement compliqué d'avancer
sans créer des perdants et de nombreux
perdants pas forcément des sommes
énormes mais on crée des perdants et ça
c'était une très grande difficulté
qu'ont tous les projets tels que leurs
produits à ses activités ou également la
proposition qu'évoquer daniel zamora du
projet assez fantaisiste présenté par la
fondation jean jaurès qui luttent
diamant créer des situations de ciment
non cohérente
donc il ya un moment il faut poser un
principe clair disant nous voulons que
chaque individu dans ce pays et ce soc
nous voulons que chaque individu
contribuer à ce financement à hauteur de
ses moyens de venir tout à fait simple
transparente que tout le monde comprenne
et là où vous êtes pour résorber le
problème de manière tout à fait
naturelle
j'ai présenté ce principe là donc
beaucoup l'instance dans toutes les
administrations auprès de l'expert qui
globalement nous pas grand chose à dire
pour pour
critiquer la faisabilité technique mais
la difficulté est une difficulté dirai
plus haut niveau des idées typiquement
daniel zamora qui lui d'un combat
égalitariste qui veut travailler à
égaliser les conditions de la population
ne peut pas entrer dans ce schéma là et
j'ai lu son livre avec beaucoup
d'intérêt je les ai vus j'ai lu et relu
effectivement quand quand je vois ces
crises ont créé de demande il incombe à
tout à fait différent qui n'est pas du
tout celui de liberté et non
effectivement il ne peut pas entrer dans
la solution
je comprends daniel zamora l'égalité
l'égalité l'égalité je pense
effectivement qu'on ait la preuve est
potentiellement deux conceptions
différentes de la liberté et que lorsque
on a 500 euros par mois qu'on n'a pas
accès à toute une série de services
qu'on a des difficultés à payer son
loyer et ses études
la liberté est un terme très relatif et
que la liberté c'est pas simplement
avoir un plancher de revenu minimal qui
nous permettraient de vaguement
subsister la liberté c'est aussi de
pouvoir dessiner de décider de son
destin de ce qu'on veut faire dans sa
vie et pour que ça voilà il faut des
mesures qui sont aussi qui vise à
limiter la liberté du marché
elle n'est pas nécessairement la liberté
de chaque individu ne ne sera pas
nécessairement dans la liberté
collective il ya quand même des conflits
là dedans il ya des arbitrages qui sont
qui sont importants li kath & kim jee
vous y avez réfléchi vous à un revenu
universel plus si enfin plutôt un revenu
de base plus ils blé donc il ne serait
plus universel qui remplacerait les
les aides principales qu'on peut toucher
aujourd'hui et est ce que vous êtes
arrivés à la même conclusion que mal de
bastia en fait déjà pour une raison très
simple
enfin pour pour nous' nous ce n'est pas
un revenu de base parce qu'il n'obéit
pas à la définition qu'on en donne quand
un revenu de base c'est tout simplement
le la traduction bgc income qui en fait
implicitement a un caractère universel
c'est pour ça que on est assez dérangé
par certaines propositions qui parle de
revenu de base et qui n'en sont pas
enfin pour nous vraiment revenu de base
est revenu universel ce sont des
synonymes
et c'est vrai que côté notamment côté
parti socialiste et la fondation jean
jaurès derrière ils ont tendance à
appeler revenu de base ce que vous
décrivez c'est à dire le simplification
de toutes les aides
une mise en commun de toutes les aides
alors que pour nous ce n'est pas ça
c'est certes une simplification
même si comme mark l'a signalé l est pas
si simple à faire et finalement nous
avons des difficultés à faire mais ce
n'est pas un revenu universel et 2e
récupération donc on va citer tout à
l'heure le revenu universel d'activité
du gouvernement d'un revenu universel
d'activité c'est à dire qu'on va
conditionner l'attribution d'un minima
social ou revenu à la recherche aux
pinces qui est déjà le cas d'ailleurs
pour le rsa mais aussi à la recherche
d'emploi ce qui est d'ailleurs un peu
déjà le cas pour le rsa alors que fort
heureusement c'est pas vraiment
appliquée mais on demande aux gens
vraiment enfin normalement sans réponse
deux offres d'emploi adéquates
on peut ne plus toucher le rsa
aujourd'hui et le huard a l'air de
vouloir consacrer ce fonctionnement de
tout ça pour dire qu'il ya des
récupérations
alors pour nous c'est le signe que
l'idée progresse mais ce sont aussi des
dangers que l'on a tendance à signaler
mais vous l'aurez compris sur l'idée de
juste travailler sur une simplification
des aides
cela reste des aides pour nous c'est
stigmatisant une revenu universel c'est
vraiment la consécration de la
solidarité nationale
de fait de reconnaître que chacun
contribue à la société pascal sanaa je
suis en désaccord avec l'idée fréquentes
dans laquelle il ya des inégalités et
dans la société
et je crois qu'il faudrait parler de
diversité est une des caractéristiques
des êtres cris cayrol à ses propres
jours ses propres activités ses propres
capacités et grâce à l' échange ils
arrivent quand même à profiter de ce qui
est fait pas preuve par les autres et
vouloir que il y ait égalité des revenus
par exemple c'est quelque chose qui me
paraît totalement contestable
d'autant plus comme je vous ai déjà dit
que les revenus sont variables de tout
au tout au long de la vie donc c'est une
une raison aussi de ne pas pratiquer une
politique comme cela alors on vient de
parler de du fait que l'europe universel
produits de base permettrait de
remplacer la diversité des transferts
par un transfert unique
c'est la raison pour laquelle milton
friedman le célèbre économiste libéral
et semblait être préférable devait elle
semblait être d'accord avec le revenu
universel
on dit souvent le même les libéraux sont
d'accord pour rendre universel mais ils
étaient huit ont été simplement
favorables à cette idée de permettre aux
individus d'avoir la liberté de choisir
leur activité en ayant un revenu donner
et non pas une série de revenus liés par
exemple au logement etc
donc je crois que c'est un tort que l'on
quitte les libéraux sont favorables au
revenu universel
il semble que si on est favorable à la
liberté individuelle
l on ne peut absolument pas le défendre
le revenu universel mal de bastia quand
on est incompatible sûrement pas moi je
vois si vous voulez je suis un libéral
dont le but c'est que la liberté soit au
menu de chaque personne je ne parle pas
de la liberté uniquement pour les riches
je prends la liberté pour tout le monde
mais ceci dit je viens passer un très
bon moment en écoutant pascal saône a
expliqué comment milton friedman
préconise d'éviter marc universel dans
ces travaux nous c'est quelque chose
d'assez inhabituel
je suis assez heureux de leur vécu ce
moment là mais effectivement la liberté
individuelle
c'est du premier au dernier et la
liberté pas mal comprise par certains
libéraux c'est la liberté de faire ce
qu'on veut au mépris les autres ce qui
n'est absolument pas ma conception est
absolument pas la conception de beaucoup
d'ouverture du bureau du travail
voilà donc là on a un exemple
fectivement de l'analyse un peu erronée
au niveau de l'association air que je
préside nous faisons un travail
approfondi en ce moment justement pour
analyser les différentes types
d'objection qui a par rapport au revenu
universel et je dirais même les
différents catégorique d'opposants parce
que les opposants constituer les
égalitaristes extrême style des classes
que vous les voyons les libéraux tout à
fait extrémistes également convoi piron
par ailleurs il y en a d'autres où nous
travaillons ces catégories là de manière
à publier peut-être années un travail
cette question là pour clarifier le
débat aujourd'hui le débat est très
mélangées départ justement des opposants
qui quittent qui apporte des arguments
qui sont trop décalé par rapport à la
réalité de ce que nous proposons
vraiment qu'ils étaient tous une
solution assez simple et direct et
efficace pour toute la population alors
vous voilà donc mis aux extrêmes pascal
salin et et et daniel zamora et zamora
dernier mot l émission est presque
terminée oui bah si je veux dire interne
et mousseux être aisément sur le travail
parce que toute cette question de la
liberté
de manière abstraite salaire bien joli
mais dans l'avenir et les gens doivent
trouver un travail et les conditions
dans lesquelles il est exact ce travail
est souvent difficile et une des raisons
pour laquelle le des économistes comme
friedman méouchy stiegler et d'autres
qui sont des économistes néolibéraux ont
bon promu cette idée c'était précisément
pour déréguler le marché du travail
c'est-à-dire abolir le salaire minimum
il était tout à fait contre l'idée d'un
salaire minimum et pour dès lors vous
pourriez cumulé votre allocation
universelle avec votre revenu
uber dès l'hiver ou etc ce capitalisme
de plate forme et ça je pense qu
évidemment le cette mesure peut
accompagner par cette dérégulation des
marchés du travail et c'est une question
qui doit en tout cas nous nous maintenir
éveillé pascal sala vous n'êtes pas
sensible à cet argument que le revenu
universel
ben ça supprimerait le smic et les
entreprises en bénéficierait à
directement mcdo sur quelques arguments
qui peuvent indiquer que sa stalle
politique meilleur que la politique
actuelle mais ça ne me permet pas et ça
me paraît pas être comme une
justification suffisante du revenu
universel pour les raisons que j'ai déjà
indiqué les catégories dernier et
dernier mot
mais non j'ai cette aventure sur la
suppression j'explique nous évidemment
on est contraint le revenu universel
qu'on prône une enfin et pour nous il ne
doit surtout pas être une régression
pour la protection sociale donc il vient
s'ajouter enfin remplacer quand c'est
quand il a le niveau par exemple du rsa
a remplacé le rsa ils ne remplacent pas
tous les systèmes assurantiels que sont
l'assurance maladie le chômage la
retraite est effectivement évidemment on
est contre la suppression du smic voilà
en tout cas là où va ma ferme et donc un
dernier mot pour dire que pour nous il
ya une vraie opportunité là qui ce qui
se dessine pour le revenu universel
c'est un sujet qui revient vraiment en
force
il était déjà venu en force en
12h07 grâce à benoît hamon même si dans
sa première mouture qui était un vrai
revenu universel
ensuite lors de sa campagne il a un peu
dévoyé
je pense que ça l'a desservi mais ç'a eu
le mérite de vraiment faire connaître le
sujet à la population française et nous
on a vu une différence entre avant et
après dans les actions d'éducation
populaire qu'on mène voilà les gens
connaissent enfin les gens ne
connaissaient pas forcément ensuite ils
connaissaient mais ce n'est pas
forcément pour beaucoup de réticences
notamment sur tout ce qu'on a déjà dit
on le fait que je le redis gens parce
que l'émission est terminée déjà vick
était grande j donc juste veut désormais
à ce que vous vouliez vous les verrez
alors du coup enfin juste pour dire
qu'avec le coc vide on voit vraiment que
ça revient et que manu de manière
beaucoup plus positif maintenant je
pense vraiment que pour l'élection
prochaine ce sera un vrai sujet et
dernière chose il y à une initiative
citoyenne européenne qui est en cours
une sorte de pétition européenne donc si
vous voulez la signer allez sur le site
jamais fermé revenus ne peuvent point
faut pour signer la pétition
merci merci tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à ce débat merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]